such a big part I think of a career and
it's something that people don't think
about that much but it's the Arc of a
career meaning you want to make sure
that you're pushing yourself and you're
trying different things and the
different chapters have a different feel
and are testing you in different ways
that's something I've always thought
about is I remember I don't know why but
when I was unemployed and in my early
20s we my my writing partner and I got a
job right away and then it went away
after like a year or two
and we didn't have work and I was
sitting in a dupar's coffee shop at like
11 30 in the morning
and trying to make my breakfast last as
long as possible because I had nowhere
to go and I'm looking out at like
Olympic Boulevard and I've got the LA
times and I'm petrified because every
cars are just whizzing by and all I'm
thinking about is that is a very
familiar feeling everybody else has a
place to be and I don't and did this not
work and what if this doesn't work the
thing that occurred to me when I was
going through that was
I don't care what happens to me I just
want it to be interesting and I
practically said it out loud to the
point where the waitress was like what
do you want do you want hash browns no I
said whatever happens to me I want it to
be interesting you want some interesting
hashbrowns you're not listening to me
wait a minute tell me more of these
interesting guys so that's a really like
cinematic moment in Duke parse and I
know that feeling and especially when
you're younger if you're somebody who
overthinks like should I do this job or
not do this next job and it was really
bad when I was younger I was like but
everybody knows I did mean girls so I
can't do the class which was a very
short-lived sitcom I did because she's
sort of similar to The Mean Girls
character and my agent had to be like
nobody cares nobody cares nobody cares
nobody is tracking you in the way that
you think they are that is a very
important Revelation that I had to have
55 times yeah you do which is I'm the
king of the overthink and all the best
things in my life I mean that's not true
there's there's preparation and there's
hard work and there's really trying to
put a lot of thought into something
that's all valid and then there are
these moments where you just say I don't
know I'm just gonna go do that thing and
it's how this podcast happened I mean it
was it was uh not me it was Adam sacks
over there and a couple of other people
saying you should do a podcast and me
thinking why would I do that yeah I have
a television show and I said it like uh
Ted Knight on the Mary Tyler Moore Show
why would I do that I have a television
and the minute we started doing it I was
like well this is just fun yeah this is
just really fun and in a greedy way you
came on my late night shows like like
five times or six times you were on a
number of times and I always loved
talking to you but we never could have
done this no in that world never and
this is more meaningful to me oh totally
it's a it's impossible to I mean those
those like the nightly
talk shows are terrifying because you do
I mean terrified for me I I really go
through quite some gastrointestinal
Olympics before and let's talk more
about that yeah so what happens is
um the small intestine meets well you'll
see do you want me to edit that out no
no I want to I want you to do that
add-on yeah yeah
um yeah this is way and I'm in many ways
like I I like what you were saying
before about you have to kind of grow
with the times and all of that and I'm
really bad at that I am minutes away
from being on a porch with a shotgun
like get off my like I am a get off my
law an old person I'm like six months
away from that and I think most of the
internet stuff is horrible and I hate it
and I keep waiting for everybody to
realize it was a bad idea we should go
back to how things were before yeah but
podcasts are like one of the it's like
one of the only exceptions right because
this is better like why wouldn't you
want to actually talk to a human yeah
and do it in a way I mean obviously
getting to the time that uh my wife and
I and you and Tom we got to hang out
together and have dinner recently with
our good friend Amy Littman Robin
Defender shout out to them
because if my friend Amy Litman finds
out that I had a podcast with you I know
um and you and she her name did not come
up Amy Whitman Whitman I feel like we
should talk about Amy lemon she is great
she's a genius she was one of the main
creative forces behind Masters of Sex
yes that's where I met her She Wrote
the episode that I'm the most proud of
Masters of Sex this episode
called the fight oh I know this one yes
she's like
she's Next Level Amy Littman yeah I've
known her since my
uh sophomore year of college that's
crazy and she'll maybe get mad at me for
telling this story but
I ran the Lampoon when I was there the
comedy magazine and we're in this
building and we would have these crazy
parties uh every couple of weeks and
um I did not drink at all the whole time
I was in college and it was an
organization pretty much of um
borderline alcoholics so why didn't you
because you were like focused on yeah it
was really well also I come from a
family that that just uh um my there was
a ingrained Terror of alcoholism right
which is earned in my family and any
probably Irish Catholic Family the way
that my people handled it going back
several Generations was no alcohol
absolutely none so I grew up in a
completely dry house never touched
anything and it never even occurred to
me in college like well no I'm not going
to do that I would be in charge of this
place where people are drinking massive
amounts of beer wine anything you can
imagine spirits and then there's a
nitrous tank somewhere and I'm supposed
to be in charge but I'm nitrous yeah I
know it was ridiculous
I was like is someone going to do some
welding no you idiot we're gonna suck on
this until we almost die oh no but
anyway we'd have these party 30s and
this uh it was hilarious because right
across the street in Adam's house on the
first floor in a window uh was a friend
of mine who was there who would always
call
the cops because it was too loud because
she was working on her writing and so it
was brother no yes it was she would call
the cops now listen to be fair it wasn't
the Cambridge cops it was the Harvard
Police which is you know and so they
would just come by and they knew me so
like ding dong and people would be like
but you know whatever yeah Soft Cell
would be playing upstairs
and I would go downstairs and open the
door
and they'd be like hey Colin and be like
hey guys too loud honey went yeah we got
a call all right well fellas I'm really
sorry I'll make sure we turn it down and
and then I would cross the street and
Amy would be there at her window and it
was so nice because it was nothing
antagonistic about it at all she beat
her typewriter working away brilliant
writer even then and I would walk up and
because her window was practically at
face level I'll just walk up to the
window and go like hey Amy and she'd be
like hey Conan and I'd be like too loud
huh and she went yep yep had to call
that's all right hey what you working on
we would just sit there and chat what
did she call you why didn't she like
just well first of all Nick Conan
because she's not gonna she's she's
working first of all I'm actually on her
side on this one I know you clearly are
I am not on yeah
there's no cell phones back then and
there's no like calling the castle that
would be like you know calling the
Playboy Mansion during a an orgy you
know no one's gonna pick up the phone
hey Telly Savalas put your pants on and
go get the phone you got it baby you got
it baby
put on a bra and go get that phone not
one big enough
I've tried 30 bras they're all too small
I'm not getting that phone so yeah I'm
on her side with this one but anyway
that's a crazy that's a really funny
story but it was a little bit like
there's that old cartoon that old Warner
Brothers cartoon of the Sheepdog and the
coyote who are yeah Ralph and Sam and
they're Arch enemies but then the
whistle blows they're each trying to
kill each other and then there's a
whistle blows and they're like that's it
for the day and they both check out and
what and that was that was Amy and I did
the I mean the other people who were
having fun
we were going to get shut down anyway
someone was going to call it just always
happened to be Amy
wow no this never ends with a lifelong
friendship
that was probably the volume level too
and she's like turn it down I can almost
hear it did part of you want the party
to end too it kind of feels like you
were hoping someone would call so yeah
you know what there's a good chance yeah
there's a good chance it'll later come
out that I called Amy yeah
can you please call the Harvard cops if
I hear a Soft Cell one more time Conan
I'm working on myself I'm trying to work
it doesn't bother me I can't hear it you
can dance if you want to you can leave
your friends behind because your friends
can't dance and if I swear to God
God that music it's really hard to be
romantic about that music now like if
there's ever the Conan O'Brien story and
they they show a scene of it oh my God
he played by Eddie Redmayne
and it's like me 1983 the castle the
Harvard Lampoon Castle in Cambridge
getaway and I've got to I'd watch it I'd
watch it two the lowest grossing movie
of all time I don't know
you did cast Eddie Redmayne as an 18
year old boy
I could do it you could do it he could
do it if anybody can do it red main yeah
also usually the the person who doesn't
like EXP experiment at all in in high
school you in this story goes crazy in
college but you kept it I did not kept
it tight some would say I waited we're
still until I met you yes
and the minute I met you I was like okay
I'm gonna have nine Guinness in this
real Pub
Ye Old it was yield I didn't remember
that would you know do you remember the
name the something in the something you
know it's always the cribble in the
Jabba yeah the slide is enough t-shirts
haha